all right it looks like we're now live
so this is the political theory
and practice discussion for may 2021 i'm
glad to be able to
start these up again and
this time were approaching a topic that
i was going to talk about last month
um then i i didn't actually do some of
the events
for last month i was a little bit down
about my uncle
dying um so i'm doing this this month
and i'm happy that everybody can join me
for this uh hopefully quite interesting
discussion i'm going to be talking about
aristotle
and the issue of natural and unnatural
slaves
and masters now you notice that i'm
talking about
people rather than just talking about
slavery
because i think a lot of the takes on
aristotle and slavery
as we're going to see are actually wrong
um he doesn't he doesn't actually bring
up slavery
as you know sort of a comprehensive
practice or way of organizing society
or those sorts of things um before we
get
into the the sort of talk and discussion
i'll give you
kind of a uh overview of why i wanted to
do this and so why talk about aristotle
and
slavery um my my reason for this
is in part coming out of all of the
discussions that we see recently about
cancel culture
and there's this great danger that
aristotle's gonna get cancelled
which frankly i think is kind of bs you
know i think a lot of this is hysterical
and overblown
um i'm you know i i teach aristotle all
the time
nobody's actually approached me and said
how can you teach this guy you know
except for
actually nobody in my classes or
universities has ever done that it's
only been a couple
you know people who are uh randos on on
the internet
and i think that's really the case in
most places and
the other thing i'll say about it too is
if you're at a place that's not teaching
aristotle
it's not like you can't study him on
your own or
find other places where he is being
taught
and it is important to be able to talk
about
philosophers without putting them on
some giant pedestal where
you know nothing they ever did was wrong
there's kind of a happy medium between
the
um not realities we'll say but the the
worries of cancel culture on the one
hand and then like uh
let's all hang out and everything goes
totally free speech on the other hand
there's probably a happy medium of
prudent thinking about this
well-informed thinking about this so
that's part of what i want to do
in this session and
um you know when it comes to
a lot of this discourse about aristotle
and and slavery i think that not only
aristotle himself
as we're going to see but also you know
thinking well-informed people
should be kind of skeptical about these
blankets you know
aristotle's a terrible guy kind of kind
of dismissals and calls for
his head or whatever it's going to be
and they should also be
really skeptical of the defenders of
aristotle who don't actually seem to
know much about aristotle
and want to endorse you know hierarchies
and things like that based in race or
gender
things along those lines so you know
what's the main issue so in our
today's culture we can say it's what's
drawn from aristotle's
texts but not actually there
in the text and i'm going to present you
here right now
we might come back to this a little bit
later on with kind of an argument you
could say
about um
how the how these things go so so
aristotle
does seem to think that some people are
what he calls slaves by nature or
natural slaves
uh you know who say is the the term that
he's using there meaning like in
accordance with nature
and this has to do with deficiencies
within
the intellect or in some cases cultural
development we'll talk about why all of
us
actually would be you know in some
respect you know
natural slaves from from aristotle's
heleno-centric
perspective because we're all barbarians
right even contemporary greeks by the
way i think aristotle would consider
them
just as barbaric as everybody else
so there's that right and aristotle
is actually concerned for those people
he says that it's better for them
to have somebody else making the
decisions for them uh
it's better for them to have masters
better for them to have rulers
somebody who tells them what to do and
arranges them within a larger context of
the household
and perhaps even society
now the problem that arises
is that this whole idea was sort of
plucked out of aristotle's works
ignoring all the rest of aristotle's
stuff by people who wanted to justify
enslavement of native americans
and then africans and use aristotle as
essentially like a
a proof text the way that
fundamentalists do in the bible
um to try to justify a racially
based slavery you know and how do you
get there well you have to make
sweeping massive assumptions about the
intellectual and cultural developments
of various you know peoples tribes
nations races which turn out to be
complete [ __ ] you know both
historically
and in terms of like you know whatever
genetics
shows us right so you have to buy into a
lot of
stuff that was in some respects popular
at the time but people had a reason
for buying into it because it made them
feel better about themselves and about
the
horrible actions that they were engaging
in or the practices that they were doing
so aristotle just like the bible was
used by
you know american southern slave holders
to justify
a racially based slavery that
made all sorts of you know sweeping
assumptions about um
races and peoples and stuff like that
that turn out to be completely
unfounded um and
that's a problem so what do we do with
the fact that aristotle can
be appropriated in that way well this is
a bigger problem
philosophically right we we can say that
listen if aristotle were around and he's
he was seeing these southern
slaveholders or
people and you know people aristotle was
also used
by uh the spanish and the portuguese in
south america to justify slavery
enslaving the the native americans there
aristotle would have come on the scene
and said uh two things one is
hey you uh you know white americans
uh spaniards and portuguese you're all
natural slaves too because you're not
greeks
and then maybe that would go away after
he
abandoned that and then he would say
what you're doing here is a complete
travesty
clearly what you're doing is wrong and
that's what's
that's what was missing now there were
people who were using aristotle
to to argue that but they were largely
ignored
so you know there are some things as
well in aristotle that we should say are
problematic i don't want to whitewash
him
and say that in you know politics book
one
when aristotle tells us for example
that rule ruling is very important and
that there is
kind of a a natural hierarchy
um you know man over woman uh
parent over child um uh
master over slave right uh when he's
speaking in very very general terms
about this i think that we we do want to
say well
you know he was wrong about that and if
we as i mentioned
in many other places if we brought
aristotle into the contemporary
classroom and he saw that
there's usually more women than men uh
in my classes
and he saw them speaking um you know
quite intelligently
about the materials i think he would
have been these
these beliefs that he had about that but
you know we shouldn't pretend that
aristotle didn't say those things and he
does say those things
in politics book one so there's this
stress on
rulership the you know the ruler and the
rule
that very easily gets turned into
a let's have rigid hierarchies and it
fits in with certain
um you could say cultural movements of
you know the 19th century the 20th
century
21st century and aristotle himself would
probably be against it
so let's talk now about what's in
error stop what what is actually there
and then we'll we'll do some discussion
so there's already an interesting uh
point about the republic and that is
actually
going to be um relevant here
aristotle begins politics the
book as a whole and politics book one
by stressing to us that there are
different relations
of ruling and being ruled and
it's a huge mistake to blur these
together to mix these up to not
distinguish these from each other
he thinks this is actually a big problem
in
the greek polities of his time and all
the other
places in in the earth as well
and um he singles out there
that the political relationship the
relationship within the household
between
you know husband and wife the master
slave relationship
these are different from each other and
we should not
mix these up he'll actually talk about
the barbarians and who does he mean by
barbarians
everybody else right uh including us
at the time we in this time we would be
barbarians because we're not
from his culture he says that they
they make a mistake in treating women as
if women were slaves
not not understanding that there's a
vital differentiation that needs to be
made there
is he right about that i mean probably
not
but he is he is calling attention to
something quite important
by saying this he also would say that
within a tyranny
everybody's being treated as essentially
a slave of the despot
and as barklord is poorly pointing out
you know this is a long-standing thing
in in greek philosophy the tyrant him or
herself
is actually a slave a slave to
their own passions and then everybody
else is a slave to them and their stupid
crazy commands right
so people who can't run their their own
show really ought not to be put into
power
and when they are we end up having a
sort of like
a despotic situation that's the word for
for you know master they're desperate
right uh the the master over slaves
um so that's one important point we
we aristotle thinks we really need to
keep these things distinct from each
other
he also mentions that in his own time
there is a range of views on slavery and
this is a very important
thing to keep in mind when people are
tempted to say oh well you know
aristotle he couldn't have really
thought differently he was a creature of
his own time
[ __ ] that's not the case at all
aristotle
actually was one of the first
comparative political
theorists he and his his research
assistants
including his friend theophrastus
carried out
studies of every constitution
meaning every main way not not written
constitutions
that's a new thing uh with us but
constitution meant
how is a a society organized what is its
history
how does its how does its politics work
he did that for all of these greek
city-states and even some colonies we
only have one
the constitution of athens and that's
you know pretty comprehensive
theophrastus actually followed that up
by looking at all of the legal codes
we've lost all of those as well but so
aristotle knew
what the range of possible opinions were
one of the things that's very
interesting is he says
some people think that all slavery is
by force and against nature he doesn't
name who these are
but he clearly thinks that this is
something that needs to be taken
seriously
and he's he's trying to say no in some
cases slavery actually
you know the relationship does make
sense you get the idea that for
aristotle
most slavery actually is just based on
force
against nature and therefore unjust
so that's another very important point
and again
how would you find this out by actually
reading the politics
by looking at what the guy said which
should be
you know for anybody who wants to debate
about these things that should be like a
minimal requirement that you've
you've read through the material several
times
getting to the the real crux of the
issue
another point that he wants to make is
that by nature
foosa in in greek different
there's different relations of the ruler
and ruled and these
what do they depend upon not just to
tell us
of what you're trying to do not just the
framework are we talking about a society
are we talking about a household
they depend on the faculties of the soul
they depend on
how well you're able to think and think
for yourself about what's good for
yourself and how to
you know get along and behave in society
as well so that's what the real crux is
it has zero to do with race i mean
aristotle does
think that the barbarians are less
developed than the greeks he has this
sort of
heleno ethnic centrism and it's really
interesting because there is a
letter and we're not sure if it's a real
letter from aristotle to
alexander but it is kind of reflective
right alexander the great who was
aristotle's student for uh a time and
would have known him through
aristotle's connections his family
connections to the macedonian court
which went you know back to his father's
generation
alexander had this this idea of
bringing together greek and persian and
admittedly other cultures
as well into one vast oikonomi okay one
big
sort of household an economy
and cultural sphere
and he he didn't succeed in creating a
lasting political
regime although you could say this allow
kids and the later you know
uh doctrines and stuff like that maybe
that's that's a reflective
thing of that but um he did succeed in
in spreading
uh these these cultures and creating a
lot of
fusion right and aristotle thought this
is a terrible idea barbarians
you really you shouldn't be treating
them as if they're greeks
uh because they are kind of you know
naturally slavish
and you're you're not you're not
thinking this through alexander
we don't know whether that letter's you
know true or
truly by aristotle or not i think it's
in plutarch
but it is kind of reflective of of his
his views
um another key point and this is
something that's almost
always totally left out if there are
going to be natural slaves
they can only be a natural slave in the
real sense
in relation to a natural master
i want to stress this if there it's not
as
it's not like natural slave is an
absolute term it's a relative term
it's only better for you to be a slave
to
somebody who actually does have your
best interests at heart has some level
of moral development
is intellectually gifted you know has
this capacity for ruling
here's the central question we should
ask yourself anytime that somebody talks
about natural slaves
is are the people who are in charge
really natural masters or should
are they more like natural slaves if we
think about the
american southern aristocracy that
eventually turned into the confederacy
of the united states of america
while there were some gifted people
among them there weren't more gifted
people among them than there were in the
north or there were in
um you know you know europe at the time
or china or india or any of the you know
african states and societies that
existed
as a matter of fact most of them would
probably themselves be natural slaves
if it weren't for the fact that they
were white and rich
so there's something about being a
master
if for aristotle if you don't really
have your proverbial [ __ ] together
you're not a natural master and nobody
should be listening to you
and you shouldn't own anybody and you
shouldn't give orders to anybody
we can say the same thing and you know
if we want to transpose this into other
sort of power relations
the proverbial uh boss's nephew
or or kid who comes in
to a company nobody should listen to
them they shouldn't be given
any authority whatsoever because they're
full of crap and entitled and don't know
what they're doing and they had it too
easy we could go on and on and on right
if you don't have the requisite moral
development and intellectual development
and capacity to rule you are not a
natural master and without the natural
master the idea of the natural slave
loses a lot of its force this is
something that's absolutely central
there's another thing that's really
important there's a discussion
of a problematic of slaves and virtues
i'm going to read a little section from
the politics now aristotle's
resolution of this towards the end is
well you know the slave how much virtue
do they need
just enough to actually like you know
not steal stuff and you know do their
job and
all of that that's the resolution that
he has but before he gets to that
he actually raises some really
interesting
problems he says
there the difficulty might be raised
does a slave possess any excellence
besides their merits as a tool and a
servant more valuable than these
for instance temperance courage justice
and any of the other moral virtues or do
they have no excellence beside their
bodily service
so this is a real problem he says
either way there's a difficulty
if slaves do possess moral virtue
how do they differ from freemen how do
they different differ from
people who shouldn't be enslaved but
should be allowed to have their own
thing so if a slave does have virtue
aristotle is suggesting maybe they can't
be a slave
and you know if you think about the ways
in which
servitude could in some cases actually
promote
virtues if it's done properly you almost
have to
you know be ready to let your slaves no
longer be slaves aristotle by the way
freed his slaves in his will when he
died and this is a
pretty common greek phenomenon the other
thing he says
is if they don't possess virtue this is
strange because they're human beings
and they participate in reason
right so
if you're treating a slave as a human
being
at a certain point maybe you can't
rightly enslave them anymore and so this
is why we see that
very often in the past again
particularly in race-based slavery
there is this incredible pressure to
dehumanize people's oh you know
africans native americans they
actually we could talk about you know uh
chinese in in in the
west coast um oh they just they they're
not the same as as other people well
that's
from an aristotelian perspective that's
[ __ ] you know
and that's reflective of a moral failure
on the part of the people saying those
things
so it's in you know the situation gets
more and more tangled doesn't it when we
look at aristotle the last thing that
i'll say and then i'll start taking some
of these
questions and comments there's also the
issue of technology
the slave is a piece of technology they
are an insole
tool aristotle actually talks about two
different kinds of
tools in his works that are you could
say
master tools right there's the hand the
tool of tools the organon
of organons and then there's the slave
who is an insole tool
who can do more than a hand because they
have hands and they can be
set to do tasks that otherwise couldn't
be
done by themselves and aristotle gives
us an example
if we had a you know for weaving right
making fabric
if we had looms that worked by
themselves and the shuttle would go back
and forth
we don't need a slave to do that and now
think about our own time
we have technology to do all sorts of
things you know
and we've been using uh
mechanics robotics ai logistics to
create a world in which um there are
more and more sophisticated
tools and the big promise of this is
that well we could we could have a
society that didn't require
oppressive power relations and it
doesn't have to be slavery it could be
economic relations between um people
you know we think about capitalist stuff
you know the capitalist
uh owner and the the worker right or we
could think about
um other other oppressive power
relations maybe we don't actually need
these we could have this utopian
existence in which none of none of this
would be required now aristotle would
say
um what really matters is are these
people still developing
as human beings are they developing
their intellectual and moral faculties
and simply having technology by itself
we know that that doesn't
actually promote that and the ceos of
silicon valley who are like this app is
gonna like fix people we know that
they're full of crap
um but you know this this does raise a
lot of interesting
issues and and problems all right um
let's take some of the questions and
comments and we'll get a discussion
going
so bark lord says i've been rereading
book nine of the republic about the
tyrant a slave to his own passions
and that's in books book eight as well
right
um and continues through to book ten
doesn't it um
not not slave of their own passions but
you know they're they're gonna get
theirs
when they go down to hades um yeah
this is this is a problematic those
aristotle would say you're not a natural
master if you don't actually have
control
over your own passions if you're not
developing the virtues
and one of the big problems with the
appropriation of aristotle
to justify slavery or servitude or
hierarchy
is that you know 99 of the time the
people who are doing that
are pieces you know from aristotle's
perspective pieces of crap
who haven't actually developed
themselves and have no business telling
anybody else what to do
this is a big big issue you know and so
we always want to push back and say what
right do you have to
be in charge this is this is a central
political question
and i would say that you know aristotle
of course does not consider
like the modern corporation or anything
like that the business environment
capitalism but we really should push
back against the people who are in
charge in the workplaces and say
who the hell are you to boss people
around where where are your
qualifications
if you think that you're suited to rule
um the fact that you have the money
doesn't mean that you
you have any you know qualifications um
the fact that you
managed to build a business over here
doesn't mean that that business
uh practice or model transfers over to
this one
you know one of my one of my friends who
actually is a ceo of a
pretty significantly large corporation
he's very honest about it he'll say i'm
not
any smarter than anyone else i just made
some decisions that turned out to be
retrospectively good decisions and
people come to me all the time saying
what do you think about this what do you
think about this and he says
i don't know i'm not an expert on that
go ask the experts you know
um you know so we really
we really do want to consider who are
the people who are
in the place of the masters um
barklord follows up my reading of the
natural slave is more like that some
people tend to be followers or need
guidance or leadership from others
one person could mature from one face
the next so the first part of that
um aristotle doesn't say that right
but that doesn't mean that we couldn't
expand
aristotle's treatment there are you know
there are a lot of people who are
natural followers there are a lot of
people who are
natural leaders in the sense that they
want to be in charge
then there's also you could say natural
leaders in a very different sense
of people who are like holy crap things
are messed up i gotta
nobody else is gonna step in here i
gotta i gotta do this and and fix it
and very often they don't want to be in
leadership positions
but are stuck in it a great example of
that is the guy that i'm
named after gregory the first pope of
rome
right bishop of rome pope
who was a benedictine monk who really
wanted nothing else then to be
left the hell alone to do his prayers
and
studies and stuff like that but he was a
very competent cable administrator
at a time when rome was falling apart
due to you know barbarian invasions and
the collapse of the economy
and actually some some global cooling
was was playing a role in that as well
um and you know that he kept getting
getting sucked in and they made they
made the guy pope
anselmo canterbury somebody else i do a
lot of work on did not want to be
bishop of canterbury did not want to be
abbot
actually had to be uh they had to like
forcibly put the the crow's ear in his
hand and give him a bloody nose on the
way to
the cathedral right so when we talk
about people being
leaders right we really don't want to
have
that many people who want power for its
own sake they're often [ __ ] you know
or
uh they get into stupid jockeying
contests with other people they they do
stupid projects for their own vainglory
um but there are a lot of natural
followers
that's quite true and and it could be
now you point out another really
interesting thing
that fits in very well both with what
with aristotle
and also with this this um 19th century
movement that interestingly is called
conservative liberalism
associated with like alexis de
tocqueville jon stewart mill
people like that where they're they're
essentially putting in into effect this
aristotelian understanding that
you you need to groom
leaders people need to be in positions
of um following and
not following in a slavish despotic way
but following in in the way that is
going to lead them to eventually take on
more and more and more
alexis de tocqueville saw that happening
in america through what he called the
principle of association he thought that
that was
something important for america i think
that's largely been lost in most parts
of american culture
and we can find it in other parts jon
stewart mill thought that that was that
was quite important as well mary
wollstonecraft would be another person
who would
fit into that framework so you're right
you can mature from one phase to the
next
you might not be ready to handle being
in charge
at you know 20 25 years old
but maybe at 40 years old with having
done a lot of things and accumulated
experience and proper mentoring now
you're now in a
good situation to do that um so
those are some good good points all
right uh
sans says one of the most interesting
things i read from aristotle's politics
was the comparative analysis
of foreign populations refugees
overtaking and destroying
host city-states struck me that he saw
this long ago in regard to modern arab
refugee crisis in europe
i would say that i wouldn't try to read
too much in there and this
this is again where you're going to want
to read the rest of aristotle instead of
making that jump connection
and say what would air what would
aristotle not just in that passage but
throughout the rest
say about about that what would we talk
what would he say about hospitality what
would he say about
integration what would he say about
all sorts of other things along these
these lines
mark says how's it going do you think an
ancient conception of leisure scole
is possible without slavery to support
the higher classes so that's
that's a great question and let's let's
amplify on that a little bit skolite
right
so this is the word that we actually get
school from in the old days
you got to go to school because you had
the leisure to do it because you weren't
stuck you know like selling fish
in the market or you know mining crap or
doing doing whatever you know rowing a
boat or whatever that whatever it else
it was that you were doing you know
being on military service weaving
things so yeah we do need leisure
um and you know
so i'll say two i'll say two things here
one is that
most of us in modern in a late modern
uh liberal democratic capitalist
technological society
we do in fact have a good bit of leisure
and we often piss it away
on things that were you know put in
front of us and
and were induced to desire so think
about
how many people currently
instead of like doing something more
constructive
will binge watch stuff in the streaming
media that we have available to us and
i'm not i'm not saying that that the
media is bad or anything like that
and this is the case in the past with
just with television
even when we only had um three channels
or four channels
and maybe maybe six if you're in a big
city or something way way back in the
day before cable
there were people who would watch six
hours of television a day
and never crack a book i mean soap
operas were there
to sell soap that's why they were called
soap operas and and people would just
watch these over and over and over again
so that's that's a use of schooling
that's a use of leisure
you know we we really should be using
our scollay for for better things and
do we need scole um
in order to to i mean in order to have
school a do we have to have masters and
slaves this is the central question of
our time
as we have a more and more
technologically
mediated existence again i was bringing
up you know
the revolutions in robotics a.i
logistics all these things think about
the fact that you you and i are
communicating right now using this this
uh crazy platform
you know youtube right um and we're able
to talk across continents mark is in
south africa i'm over here
in the united states in milwaukee um
you know the the great dream is that
we can have le either no oppressive
power relationships
which would include slavery but also
other things or we could have less and
less of it or
maybe people are only slaves for two
hours a day and then the rest of the
time
they they get to do what they're doing
this is a big question
having to do with technology and a lot
of it is you know why why aren't we in
the
that utopia right now that's that's
that's a question we ought to be asking
ourselves
aristotle seem to think well hell if you
have like you know things weaving
themselves you don't need slaves at all
um
why why is this the case so that that's
a
open question all right let me there's a
lot of more questions now let me
um oh here's an interesting question
from jb
should we have leadership positions by
lottery i mean i'm actually kind of
serious
so i mean some greek city states did
aristotle talks about that in politics
right sometimes it's by vote sometimes
you just choose
you know some leadership positions which
are not real
leadership but we're very valued by the
greeks jury duty you know we often try
to get out of that that's done by
lottery right i don't know what it's
like in other places but here in the
united states most people try to get out
of
jury duty i don't have to because every
time i get i get called up as soon as
they find out that i'm a philosopher
i'm eliminated immediately because they
they don't want any
anybody lawyers don't want thinkers uh
on on their juries because that's they
don't know what to make of it
but yeah i mean there there are probably
a lot of um
positions where we might actually be
better off
um using a lottery uh maybe not just a
complete lottery
just grabbing people off the street but
um
it would certainly open up opportunity
uh we do have a big problem in our
society of you know replication of
hierarchical um stratification you know
so all right uh
evan um any recommendations for readings
and each other than genealogy of
morality whatever you want to read you
know i mean you're not gonna hurt
yourself by reading any of his other
books
um genealogy is if you want something
systematic
birth of tragedy is pretty systematic um
in a way even beyond good and evil is
because it's got those chapters on
on different things but you just pick
whatever you want you're gonna have to
reread it
multiple times anyway so um
sure shots says leisure is largely
consumption
so that's an interesting point aristotle
would say that's a choice
and in a culture where leisure is
largely consumption that culture is in a
bad way
because so aristotle would distinguish
between
different kinds of activity and there's
oasis right craft production creative
work
there's praxis and praxis could include
consumption
and then there's you know um but praxis
is oriented towards
you know generating some sort of goods
within the praxis itself
so having a romantic relationship as a
praxis
you know um just wanting to get off
with somebody is i guess consumption
right i'm sitting there binge watching
netflix uh whatever series you pick or
hulu or
you know disney or hbo
whatever it is go not go uh something or
else
amazon prime you know they've got all
these different choices crackle
um just doing that without like
thinking about it you're using somebody
else's poetic production
right um but you're just consuming it
that's um aristotle would say that's
kind of a choice now it's interesting
because in our society you could say
how are people supposed to figure that
out you know
again we can talk about people being
kind of like groomed for being
passive consumers or actually being
no longer completely passive consumers
but consumers who like give a thumbs up
or share some content this is actually a
really interesting topic to think about
that might be something well worth
developing into its own
uh session to talk about
um let's see here
omar says following up on cnn's question
what do you think aristotle would say
about the arab refugee crisis in europe
well i would say it's not an arab
refugee crisis i would say that it's
it's much wider than that because it
includes a lot of people who are not
ethnically arab um in in
many respects it's it's people from
at least in name muslim countries right
um
and i think aristotle would say we have
to look at this in a
non-simplistic way you know the
um problems of getting
groups to um assimilate to the societies
that they come to
it's a different problem from society to
society isn't it because
it's one and you see this reflected in
the different uh
communities it's one thing to say um
to you know for example uh somali
immigrants
in the united states okay you need to
you need to be american and then you
have to explain well what does that
actually mean and part of being american
is actually being part of this melting
pot right
it's another thing to say about um
somalis and
sweden it's another thing to say it uh
about
uh and we'll switch back to arabs arabs
in in france
you know or turks and germany right um
or pick whoever you want syrian refugees
in various places i i don't think
aristotle would have a one-size-fits-all
solution he would see it as a problem
that needs to be unpacked and looked at
in its various dimensions um he would
say that one thing that's really
important is figuring out how you're
going to
um i mean one thing he also say too is
listen every society is not like this
pristine wonderful place until the
immigrants come
every society is messed up already you
know
and then we we bring them into this
messed up society with its tensions
already existing and problems that were
never really solved
and now it's a little bit more
complicated right and it's interesting
too because
aristotle would say that people who are
like um using refugees as a scapegoat
i think he would consider them morally
depraved you know
and self-deluded um that's
sort of my off-the-cuff view on that all
right
um the internet would you agree with
reading hegel's master slave dialectic
as describing the mechanism that
underlies differences between platonic
aristotelian versus christian views on
master and slavery i would not
i would not engage in that sort of level
of high you know
generalization and oversimplification i
would read hegel's master slave
dialectic as a
tiny little part of the phenomenology of
spirit not the main thing hegel is about
not one of his absolutely central
concepts
and i would look at what plato actually
has to say
what christians actually have to say
what aristotle actually has to say
and not try to glom these things into
each other like that
um barklord we do need cooperative work
in order to create leisure and
yeah we do have cooperative work we live
in an incredibly
coordinated world right now and you know
great example of how you know how things
are so
closely connected was when that tanker
ship okay
one jackass not piloting the ship right
um managed to to really start crimping
the world economy through the dumb
decisions that they
they made right all these things are
connected with each other we have
cooperation
uh in in many respects and you could
call it in
in a lot of cases not deliberate and
often coerced
cooperation but it's still cooperation i
mean the fact that i've got
coffee in this cup right now how many
people
were involved with that set of
actions i mean we get it from this this
roaster just
uh three blocks from here called stone
creek but they work with you know people
down in south america
um to to get the the coffee grown and
then bring it up here and
all all that sort of stuff so all right
um luke and lazy would you not say that
aristotle's politics and philosophy also
presents
itself and not more non-conservative
philosophers i.e marx aristotle's not a
conservative philosopher if you actually
understand it
and you think through the implications
of his stuff um
and sure you know marx was was somebody
who was influenced by aristotle
among so many others i mentioned jon
stewart mills a progressive
right alexis de tocqueville um don't be
misled by the
by the term conservative liberal i i
made sure to you know clear that at
the start um wolfstonecraft is
influenced by
by aristotle so many others are as well
um
you know there's in in macintyrian
circles
um there's something called radical
aristotelianism
you know calvin knight would be a great
person to to look at
there's actually um interestingly in the
international society for mcintyre and
inquiry there's
quite a few old-school marxists because
guess who was an old-school marxist
mcintyre right they're mostly they're
mostly brits but there's there's a few
over
over here as well so there's there's
nothing necessarily conservative about
aristotle and as a matter of fact
aristotle would look at most
conservatives today and say
you are a bunch of like benighted
[ __ ] that you
if you're going to appeal to my work you
have nothing to do with the ideas that
i'm putting forward
um so you know that's probably enough
about
about that um lenin has a kind of funny
remark wait
should i be binging this sort of
streaming media um
i mean if you can get it i mean i i hear
that people do sometimes binge watch
some of my videos
i don't do that i mean not just because
i i'm not interested in watching myself
right i already know what i want to say
about stuff i'm not going to be
actually i am surprised every once in a
while when i go back to an old video if
i need to like
you know try to find something uh i'm
like
oh yeah yeah that's an interesting
example i've totally forgotten about
that
but i i don't i don't binge watch other
people's stuff either but that's because
i'm so busy
producing right and teaching my students
and things like that
but you know you could i mean there's
another word for
for not binge watching but something
kind of similar
reading a book right if you take a book
and you know you're you're reading
through aristotle's
politics and you're like this is not
going to be done in an afternoon
i guess this is going to take me you
know a couple days to read through
um you're kind of like doing the
equivalent of binge watching aren't you
you're sticking to some some content and
and you could be reading crap instead of
reading aristotle right
and nothing against like uh
watching media i mean my wife and i do
this all the time you know
there are shows that we particularly
like
and we get into them and you know we we
get invested in the characters
and um we get pissed off about the
writers
uh you know doing a bad job in later
seasons like in
in game of thrones you know they took
one one of the most valuable
sources of intellectual real estate out
there
and over the course of three seasons
effectively destroyed it you know
so what we want to binge watch
you know it could actually be quite
valuable to watch um
some of those things that that are out
there um
you know watching the americans was
quite interesting that not just for the
nostalgia factor of seeing the 1980s
where
my wife and i grew up uh depicted but
thinking about
um some of the crises that we went
through you know
um and how close we actually did get to
war
in in the 1980s with with warsaw pact
you know that was that was quite worth
thinking about
all right um luke and lazy are there any
good aristotelian thinkers that are also
marx's neo-marxist you could recognize i
mentioned
alistair mcintyre you know um there's
there's like a whole
circle of uh people that are connected
with him
um i mean who else
i mean i mean
the the critical theorists in the
frankfurt school are sometimes using
aristotelian ideas
they're not huge fans of aristotle of
course right because they they do
mistakenly view him as
as primarily conservative probably i
guess because conservatives have used
his ideas so much
and bastardized them um i don't know
i'll i'll think about that
uh barklord has a recommendation scott
makeley
i don't know him so
um
[Music]
all right zach i just graduated from
university this week
nice job i wanted to say thanks for
being an inspiration through it all i'll
be beginning grad school and political
science theory this summer okay that's
that's really great
and i'm glad that my videos or whatever
else i did
could be an inspiration and i would
suggest that you as much as you can try
to like pay it forward right try to
help out other people um as as much as
you can to
to understand these sorts of things
um luke and lazy i wonder if being
marxist and aristotelian like mcintyre
requires rejecting key aspects of both
philosophers
can't figure out whether marx believes
in ethics or not it depends on what you
think are key aspects
um i mean why not go to mcintyre and
read his books and find out you know
uh that's probably the best thing you
could do um
i can tell you from having been engaged
with him and
and uh people connected with him that
the answer is no but
you know i mean find out for for
yourself right
um panda aristotle said good polity only
arose out of ethnic kinship yeah and on
that aristotle was wrong aristotle also
said women are
you know deficient men aristotle was
wrong who gives a [ __ ]
right you know when you're when you're
taking a
thinker from centuries past
or in this case millennia past expect
there's going to be some stuff in there
where
if they were brought here in the present
they would be like oh yeah i was wrong
about that
i need to revise that so we don't want
to be you know fundamentalists
of the politics proof texting any more
than we want to be fundamentalists of
the bible
you know putting forth crazy
interpretations that are like
one little point it's always got to be
systematic it's always got to be
rooted in the the texts uh sure shot so
we're going to take a little diversion
here
how are you finding fang numina are acc
branches like
xeno feminism something that interests
you fair warning about following land on
twitter it's a big letdown
i would say a feng numana is not a big
letdown but it's it's
you know i've been underwhelmed by the
um
you know the what i'm actually reading
and the
massive mystique built up around nick
land and accelerationism and fang numina
i think most of that is like people
deluding themselves uh very much the way
that people do with the phenomenology of
spirit right
hegel or also spinoza's ethics is one
that that gets done with that
these are not um books that are like
somehow the revelation of everything
um and it's also you can't reduce it
down to oh
you know cool stuff man let's do some
drugs and then we'll like you know
unpack the mysteries
that's for posers that's for people who
don't really want to study and do
philosophy
all i'm finding in land's fang numina is
you know fairly interesting essays that
are the kind of stuff that we all did
back in the 90s in continental
philosophy sometimes good sometimes bad
go to you know society for
phenomenological and existential
philosophy and read a paper
that's the kind of stuff that's in fang
numina which is not bad
you know but and sometimes is insightful
but
there's a lot of cases where you're like
well you can make those connections but
you didn't bother to explain why you
make those connections
so they seem pretty arbitrary and
um you know this would take a lot more
discussion in order for it to you know
make make uh
sense why you picked this it makes sense
what you're saying but what you're
saying is
not necessarily true or all that
interesting
or you know this is a problem right and
and people
sometimes point to oh the format is
different well hell if you read avital
ronald's the telephone book back in the
90s
right you got that same sort of stuff
people were doing experimental crap like
that
you know back then we all did that sort
of stuff
so i don't know how i don't know how
land
talked people into thinking that his
book
was somehow this massive revelation i'll
also mention too another another book
that kind of fits into that
it doesn't measure up to the hype
anti-oedipus i mean it's a good book
but it ain't like you know
the revelation of everything all right
uh joshua i'm wondering since i've been
reading aleister mcintyre if you could
comment on aristotle's conception of
master slaves as it relates to
nietzsche's conception of master slave
morality not connected at all i i don't
know why
i see why okay aristotle or or
nietzsche those are not connected
uh to this right um
so i wouldn't try to try to
um squish those those categories into
each other
brett says the presence of home through
technology makes it rape
not really sure what that means um
home through technology um
maybe you're talking about like the
internet of things within the home and
the fact that like our you know our
amazon tv might be listening into
listening in us at any moment i don't
know how that makes anything rape
except in a very attenuated sense of the
term that that probably isn't
particularly helpful but you know
all right uh panda aristotle told
alexander to treat all non-greeks as
aliens we've already covered that
he'd never have ever advise something
like the sousa weddings for example yeah
we already
already discussed that um maybe that's a
true letter maybe it's not
we don't know um all right uh
trav trav dessel i think a lot of
confusion and aristotle doctrines
overlap
have done any comparative studies on the
topic people have done
tons and tons and tons of studies on
that topic there's a vast literature out
there that you just have to google
and you'll find people talking doing
comparative work of that sort
between aristotelian virtue ethics and
confucianism
so uh are there overlaps yeah and i
would say that
there's overlaps pretty much across the
virtue
ethics spectrum there's massive overlaps
between pl just
in western philosophy platonic
aristotelian
and stoic philosophy along with
much early christian work uh and you can
also mention you know uh
jewish thinkers like frilov alexandria
the epicureans are kind of outliers but
even they like recognize the four
cardinal virtues
we can um you know take all that western
stuff
and compare it to uh indian
philosophical ideas
to chinese philosophical ideas
and you're going to find lots and lots
of overlap
in part because people you know
eventually come to realize
that there's some things that you know
they may be some
to some degree culturally dependent but
we we have some problematics as human
beings that we generally
have to work out like not being a bunch
of [ __ ] to each other
right or selfish bastards or how to fix
things once they're all screwed up right
so all right um
traverse dies follows this up with
something about confucian doctrine but
he's he's actually
or she whoever they are is referencing
some confusion doctrine
not all confucian doctrine proposed to
penetrate one's chi
to stop slavery is comparable to
aristotle's metaphysics
okay you want to follow that path go
ahead and write a paper on it
make sure that you you clarify which
confusions you're talking about because
that ain't confucius or the menchus or
any any of the early stuff
you're talking about like neoconfusion
stuff but that's fine
um all right uh
near here mentioned something that i
brought up earlier aristotle freed his
slaves in his will yeah and a lot of
people did that sort of thing
um dylan for someone who is an aristotle
beginner what would you recommend to
start with
i have a video on that that you can you
know google
and uh there's all sorts of advice in
there about how to get started with
studying aristotle
uh fenton mccann says i tried to write
this out perfectly for 20 minutes right
after the perfection fallacies lectures
as well
i owe you more i wish i could give more
oh that's that's very nice but what were
you trying to write out perfectly
um i'm not quite sure what that
refers to um but yeah that's that's
thanks all right uh
it's a little hard to read here with my
my
the little script there's somebody's got
their stuff in greek
uh konsta
says is it possible to use aristotle's
point of view on creating an ideal
society
in the base of eudaimonia if we can't
grasp an objective idea of happiness or
virtue
yes i mean whoever told you that you
can't grasp
an objective idea of happiness or virtue
i mean why make that assumption to begin
with
but whatever objective means to you
because objective is not
objective is one of those terms people
throw around and you always get us
what do you actually mean by that right
um do you mean interest objective do you
mean like agreed upon
do you mean like they're in the world
like
scientific facts are because that's
that's kind of a crazy thing to demand
um is it possible to to create an ideal
society
on the basis of eudaimonia aristotle
wasn't particularly
um bullish on that idea i mean he
thought every existing
he says this in the politics right every
existing political
uh community at his time is deficient
and even the thing that he proposes as
like you know the best
is is still just a sketch
um ruffy bumble would a natural master
of natural slaves largely though not
necessarily out of benevolence towards
the natural slaves yeah that is part of
the idea that you see there
um it would be more like man you poor
bastards you can't really
take care of yourselves i'll i'll help
you out for a while and there probably
would be a dynamic of human development
where this would only be
for a while not for your entire life
right
and i actually know somebody who
is not treating people like slaves but
does something kind of like that
takes in um
screwed up young teenagers off the
streets
gives them a place to stay connects them
up with you know social resources that
can help them out
teaches them to code uh gives them some
you know
guidance and mentoring and then they
move on
they move out you know of that that
house um
is he a natural master i i don't know
about that but he's doing something
that's kind of a similar dynamic ibrahim
ali thoughts on hobbes
you know i've talked about hobbs a lot i
like him he's interesting
i think that he poses a central problem
for
contemporary politics um
eddie nick land is the schizo's
philosopher of choice
okay i guess if you're big on the schizo
community
that's important um lennon feng nuna
just seemed like a fun and an anxious
read it felt like mostly entertainment
i mean i i guess you could use it that
way i you know
from the very start you can see him
engaging with
important ideas you know he's right the
writings span
a considerable amount of time so like
you know one of the early essays is
talking about south african apartheid
um i don't know how you get a lot of fun
stuff out of that
um but he's you know he's proposing
interesting interpretations um
mere saying do you find aristotelian
metaphysics extremely necessary to
understand his politics and ethics
not at all uh not only not extremely
necessary
not necessary um you can understand
these things independently of each other
does it add a little bit more to the
picture to understand aristotle's
metaphysics
yeah so some points it can be helpful
but it's not really
it's not really necessary um
and you know and when you're reading an
important philosopher
you don't like read the foundational
things then you read the next things and
then the next things unless they've
organized their works that way
[Music]
you just read the works and then you go
back and forth and back and forth
you know if you want to understand
aristotle's
political ethical works which include
the politics the two ethics the rhetoric
the poetics and parts of the topics
probably should throw on the soul in
there as well
you know expect that to be a process of
studying
things for about a year or two you know
and going
reading and rereading and going back and
forth and i'll tell you um
being able to being able to read it in
greek really made a big difference for
me because i could tell that like
a term that had been translated one way
in the politics and then by another
translator in the ethics that it was the
same thing that aristotle was talking
about you know
uh iraqis thank you for the work you do
what do i think of nussbaum's criticism
of virtue ethics and its approach to
emotions from a neo-stoic perspective
um i'm not a big fan of nussbaum frankly
i i don't she's she's somebody who she
doesn't have a mystique to her but i
think people
take her as being more on point and
smarter than she is
in a lot of cases um i don't think
you know i
i would say that when it comes to like
contemporary scholars on the side like
julia honest more than say
than than nussbaum um
aristotle's treatment of the emotions is
fragmentary um we find it largely in
rhetoric
book two some stuff in the ethics so to
talk about you know engaging aristotle's
theory of the emotions is already kind
of a non-starter
um and you know
it depends on which work you're your
therapy of desire you're talking about a
recent work on anger
you know i think that newspam is worth
looking at and engaging
but you know i don't uh i always take i
always kind of look at her stuff with a
jaundiced eye
i would say um
luke says do you think hagel's empty
formalism objection can be applied to
marxists who think communism can be
justified
through rational contradiction alone
without any ethic
i guess i mean i don't know this isn't
something i think about
very much there is i mean marx is it's
not like they don't have an ethics
um you have an ethics whether you like
it or not you know
you're you've got praxis you've got you
know prioritizations that you're making
you might not have something that you
call an explicit formal ethics
but nobody gets away without doing it
williamson any thoughts on how to write
notes while reading philosophy
i don't because i don't take a lot of
notes and the processes that work for me
i'm kind of an outlier
probably don't work for most people
that's something really good to ask
other people about you know what what
works for them because it might be
helpful for them
rutabagas sand castle what do i think of
arthur schopenhauer's book the world is
will and representation
it's interesting you know i don't really
buy schopenhauer's stuff all that much
he's he's a very you know in my view
good stylistic writer i enjoy
um studying him i actually did get to
take a course
uh as when i was at european graduate
school
my wife was taking uh her doctoral
classes there i got to take a class with
uh
wolfgang schumacher who has been the
president of the international shop in
schopenhauer society um specifically on
schopenhauer which was which was a real
treat because you got to work with like
you know a master on on a guy who he's
been thinking about for
years and years and he had some
interesting reinterpretations of
schopenhauer
as being not quite so pessimistic that i
found quite uh
persuasive um world is will and
representation definitely worth reading
uh i'm not a trope of hirian you know
it's interesting because schopenhauer's
really you know when i was
uh an undergrad and in grad school if
you were like yeah i'm working on
schopenhauer people would be like
oh wow i mean are you reading carl
jasper's too
you know it was sort of like
schopenhauer's one of those tiny little
rooms
off the side of the house that the
weirdos go
live in and he's had like a big
renaissance over the last like 20 years
people
people are very interested in him you
know i'm kind of surprised
but people go in and out of
vogue like that right um
[Music]
all right bark lord says i recently read
a book focusing on the concepts of
fontasia
pneuma and the vehicle of the soul from
antophone
to sinisius of cyrene's day insomnia
some prophecies dreams and human
imagination
okay well that's good i mean i haven't
read those um
but there's lots of of texts of ancient
philosophy that i haven't
um so i don't have anything to say about
that etihad what do you think about
renee gerard's memetic theory
um the theory of memetic desire you're
talking about right yeah that's
there's something to that um i i like
reading renee's girard i
haven't done anything on him uh as far
as videos go but
he's somebody who i encountered back in
grad school and
um i think you know he's got some
good good points to it
uh nick says i listened to an interview
with julian bagini today he's got some
interesting views on stoicism do i think
the stoics got anything wrong
yeah and i don't know who this julian
baghini is
i never heard of him myself um so i i
don't know that i care about his views
on stoicism
uh unless he's you know somebody who is
worth engaging
um yeah i mean the stoics are clearly
wrong about the nature of the cosmos
that would need to be updated um i i
don't you know i've said this many times
i think that they have a lot of really
helpful techniques and practices to use
for anger but i don't go
all the way down the anger is always bad
for us
um lying that they go down any more than
i do with john cassian
or any of the other thinkers who who do
that you know i'm a bit more
of a i'm a bit more
aligned with the aristotelians the
neoplatonus
and the um some of the early christian
thinkers like
augustine on that rather than you know
people like cassian
so you know and there there's there's
other aspects i mean
i'm i'm in a uh cicerone eclectic so
while there's large parts of stoic stuff
that i find valuable i don't i don't buy
into anybody's
thing 100 so all right mark says do you
think there's a worthwhile conversation
in comparing ancient greek
colonization with modern colonization
any insights you could draw oh yeah
that's a really interesting
question um there's a lot there too
right
because oftentimes colonization was a
way
they weren't doing it primarily to say
oh man we
really need to like take over these
people's territory or something like
that it's more like
we got too many damn people here some of
you are going to have to go somewhere
else
and then things that would sort of like
develop out of that
and there would be like these
long-standing
connections felt to exist between
different uh places and your colonies
matter some colonies turned into
not with ancient greeks so much but
think about
carthage carthage was a phoenician
colony that turned into
one of the most powerful city-states
of the ancient world and it wasn't just
by the way
the romans who fought against the
carthaginians it was also the greeks it
was also
piracis it was alexander
have had plans to go back and try to
fight the carthaginians who knows
you know um i saw some interesting
speculations on on that recently
on on a discussion that was going on
um so there's all of that stuff like why
did people start colonies
what were the attachments what happens
when a colony becomes bigger than
its originator
[Music]
so yeah is it can we compare it to
modern colonization
[Music]
so modern colonization is not just one
thing right
think about for example here in the
united states
the differences the different attitudes
and approaches towards
native american nations tribes peoples
between the spaniards and there was
already a range of difference with the
spaniards the english
and the french you know um
and how that was reflected in
you know marrying trading um
whether you engaged in in genocide
and and you know appropriation of lands
or not all those sorts of things you
know
um you can also talk about too the
intersection between religious
organizations
and uh political you know like the the
jesuits for example in paraguay
fighting against both the the spanish
and the portuguese raising their own
missionary armies there's such a big uh
picture can you can we compare ancient
greek and
modern colonization maybe
maybe not so much and probably we should
also look at colonization as it happened
across the world you know all right um
zen thomas uh can you suggest any more
secondary sources besides friedrich
cobblestone's history of philosophy will
it be sufficient secondary literature
depends on what you want it sufficient
for right um
i mean there's all sorts of books out
there and there's some that like try to
give you like a whole
overview a recent one grayling's history
of philosophy right it's not bad
it's it emits a lot of stuff i was i was
uh
once again uh kind of pissed off to find
mary wollstonecraft almost entirely
ignored
uh but that's the norm as a matter of
fact women authors
grayling's history is not very good on
that at all
um but you know there's
it's not as if we there's any perfect
one out there
it all depends on what you're doing i
mean there's there's like
secondary literature on particular
thinkers and figures
and um you really only know if it's
decent or not if you actually have
engaged with the original stuff
you know um so i don't have a lot of
suggestions about secondary lit
james brown how well do you think
maritime understood aristotle
i think on some things quite well and on
other things uh
it's more maritime than aristotle i
think there's a tendency
to read aristotle in rather schematic
ways
that are and also you know i would say
even on
thomas aquinas maritime is sometimes a
little bit more schematic than you'd
like but
not as bad as a lot of his
contemporaries
so you know uh
me here how often do we have these live
sessions
political theory and practice
discussions are every month i also do an
ama every month
um sometimes i do other things as well
you know i've got the world's
speculative fiction series
we just did a classic metal class
yesterday
um some of those are zoom sessions some
of those are on youtube
you gotta like actually go to my reason
io calendar or go to my
facebook author page and then i have my
events
listed you know i'm glad that you find
them enlightening and entertaining yeah
if
they ever get boring uh probably people
should let me know because that would be
that would be a time to change things up
right
uh abraham how has philosophy helped you
live out your life regarding personal
ethics religious beliefs oh
like myriad different ways i mean one of
the reasons why i do a lot of research
on the emotion of anger its
understanding and anger management in
ancient medieval and early modern
philosophy
is because i struggled with anger from
my
childhood onward some of that may
actually be
you know temperamental constitutional i
am what plato would call a thematic
person right um and that like the three
parts of the soul
there's the you know rational part the
appetite of part and then the spirited
or
passionate thematic part the part that
gets angry that jockeys for position and
power
and prestige that's me um and
and uh so you know
the stoics aristotle various christian
authors the platonists
um even some stuff from buddhism and and
from
confucianism as well as some some
other sources very very helpful for me
for
gradually working my way into becoming a
less
anger-prone and anger-directed person
over the years and even sometimes of
help to other people as well
so that's just one example i mean
there's all sorts of
examples right all right
uh bark lord are you interested in the
new idealist like bernardo castro
here on youtube never heard of the guy
so
i i have no idea who he is or what his
idealism is or anything like that but
there's always like tons and tons of
people going on and new movements and
all that you can't stay on top of all
all of this stuff so you'd have to be
the judge of whether it's worth it or
not
joe says a lot of people forget many of
the greek colonies are religious in
nature too to set up pythagorean
colonies for example or various cults to
a specific deities
those are not colonies those are more
like little
you know those when we're talking about
colonies we're talking about places that
had their entire economy
they were like cities um you could have
you could use the word colony
as like a little tiny offshoot within
that but
in any given cut in any given colony the
majority of people were not
you know there to worship hercules or to
uh be pythagoreans right they they were
there to farm and
you know live and all that other kind of
stuff
uh oh here's a great question iraq
iraqus what do i think of becker's new
stoicism
that is so going back to like talking
about
books that have like a prestige around
them
and people will buy and talk about but
not actually
read more than a little bit of it
becker's is like that but becker's is a
good book it's
it i've i've worked through it myself
independently
and then i did it also with a client it
took us four months of
weekly meetings to get through the
entire book and we didn't actually do
the logic
part at the end becker's new stoicism
was
very important very influential in
academic circles along with
you know a long's work and uh
gill and a few other people for bringing
stoicism back up to
before i i um
it's a tough book in part because
becker himself is a very terse reader he
doesn't use a lot of examples
it's very systematic and programmatic
but it's well worth checking out
[Music]
i don't i don't follow him on some of
the
points that he's making um but i can i
can appreciate where he's coming from
and so i think it's quite good to to
check out
uh grim grimax reefer are you ending the
live session
now maybe in another 15 minutes or so
um mark says i missed some of the
discussion
uh sorry if you already talked about
this do you think aristotle's status as
a medic and athens influences ideas on
barbarians and slaves now that's an
interesting question
so first we should what does that mean a
medic a resident alien
aristotle was not athenian he was from
staggered that's why we call him the
stagger right right which is
in the in the control of the macedonians
at the time
and before he he um established the
lyceum which he could not establish by
himself
theophrastus his his friend and
successor
actually owned the land of the lyceum
because
you had to be a an athenian citizen
so um he and theophrastus by the way
traveled around the aegean as well
um it's interesting because you would
think that
okay as a medic maybe he would have been
more
receptive to you don't need to be a
member of the
the you don't need to be a citizen in
order to be like a full member of the
city state and he doesn't say that
he doesn't actually say much about
resident aliens at all
um so did it influence it i don't know
there's no evidence really that it did
um
so that's kind of interesting uh grimex
do you find in aristotle's politics an
idea on the polis and slave master
dynamic the basis for anarchy
no um i don't air subtle doesn't doesn't
think that anarchy
is a good thing in part because if he
had even like conceptualized that he'd
be like well nobody's in charge
and this is this everyone's going to be
on everybody's throats
and you're not going to be able to have
you probably would have had kind of a
homsy
view of it right you can't actually do
anything you can't generate anything
um i mean could you take his ideas and
push them very very far
and bring in a whole bunch of other
stuff from the outside
and get to something like you know
anarchism in the sense of like these
well-developed individuals who can all
live together without necessarily having
to have a ruler because they're not
going to be a bunch of jerks to each
other yeah
you might be able to do that but why why
use aristotle for that basis
why not just go straight to the other
other stuff you know
um e de mont do you think
would you think a person might benefit
more talking to a good philosopher than
a psychologist
just about typical existential angst not
a serious biological imbalance
it depends totally on who the
philosopher is
who the psychologist is on the one side
and who the subject is on the other side
a lot of psychologists are actually
decent philosophers
and studied philosophy a lot of
philosophers are
terrible at managing their own lives and
i wouldn't trust them with giving
anybody advice
a lot of psychologists are also you know
quite a mess that way as well so
it really depends on what they've been
studying um
and it depends on the kind of person
that you are yeah
i am glad that you said like if you have
a serious mental
illness like a you know chemical
imbalance or something like that
a lot of people would be like oh man i'm
going to get this stoicism stuff is
going to like fix my life
well if you're severely bipolar it's not
going to do that
because you actually need some drugs and
it can help out
right the drugs can maybe um stabilize
you to the point where
now you can function a bit better and
use some of these lessons
and you know focus on the things that
actually are in your control like you
know
when you're feeling high or feeling
really low you don't control that but
you certainly control
what you do with that right um
so you know these things can there's
there's a lot of overlap between good
psychology and good practical philosophy
not a surprise psychology actually came
out of philosophy it was a
division of philosophy originally so
um oh here's a good question michael
aga agaze
what do you think of peter adamson's
history of philosophy without any gaps
i've only listened to a few episodes
i've been impressed by the ones that i
have
i like i said i don't consume a lot of
other people's stuff in part because i
don't have the time
and i i do like to live a life you know
of my own that's
um that does have time for me uh
you know going to the park taking walks
exercising hanging out with you know my
cat who's sleeping over there
um i'm not gonna try to turn it around
to show you um
you know doing things with my my wife uh
enjoying life right so a lot of i do a
lot of production i don't have that much
time for
for consumption of other people's stuff
um what i have seen is pretty impressive
and the idea the idea is really
impressive right i remember when it
first when i first encountered it so i
wasn't there when it first started
they were they were probably like maybe
i don't know 20 episodes
in and i was like oh that's kind of cool
you know this is like back in like maybe
2010 i guess and i was like i wonder if
they'll be able to see it through
you know like think about the half hour
hegel project right
um there you know there's a lot of
places where
where i could have said i'm kind of done
with this right
um i could have made an excuse and said
you know in the original
work of the phenomenology the religion
and the the uh
uh absolute knowing that's kind of
add-on stuff we'll just stop right there
and and i i didn't and peter adamson who
actually is doing a lot more stuff he
has to coordinate with all these other
people
is uh seeing it through so that's pretty
cool and it's cool that he also put out
some books
um with it as well paul says i'm really
trying to decrease my tv watching
does the prince of nothing book series
explore any of the philosophical topics
being discussed today
yeah actually um
this whole idea of like uh servitude
you know and who who the natural master
would be
so
prince calhouse is if anybody is the
natural master
or the like person of superlative
virtue who deserves to rule that
aristotle discusses in book three and
says you gotta watch out for these guys
because because they they can be good at
the time but then
success succession plans are a real real
problem
um you know yeah a lot of these themes
are being addressed in there
um it's a great series i really you know
i'm rereading
uh book three right now for the third
time
to get ready to shoot some video on it
this week for the uh the session we'll
be having
next next weekend bringing the series to
a close
and wow it is it is really something
um it'd be cool to meet backer you know
chat with him a bit
although maybe he'd be bored with
somebody like me
william zen what are your thoughts on
the youtube channel contra points
never watched it so i don't know i see
people talking about it
um but i don't know if it's any good or
not abraham ali
do i think religion is a necessity for
the functional operations of the state
and society
obedience sticking to norms keeping the
peace within society
no i think you can do those in other
ways
and i would also say that when religion
is reduced to that
then you get some real problems because
you very quickly lose
the religion you know the religiousness
of religion and it just turns into
some more ways of controlling people
uh nicola nikolov uh greetings from
bulgaria nice watching your stream on a
sunday evening yeah it would be
evening over there that's cool abraham
follows up are there any well-known
modern hobby and philosophy
philosophers yeah um
uh i forget his first name he died a
while back his name was kavka
he wrote some stuff on hobbs that um
gregory kobka i want to say um
that were quite interesting he was like
looking at hobbs in mostly game
theoretic
ways uh gautier his morals
by agreement book is is quite good um
gene hampton has written quite a few
interesting things in hobbs over the
years
um
those are those are the people who come
to mind right away i mean there's a lot
of people who
engage the hobsy and problematic and
talk about
hobbs in interesting ways you know leo
strauss who i'm not a huge fan of
but i think his stuff on hobbs is
actually pretty good
hannah rent talks about hobbs there's
quite a few people who who
use hobbs but they're not hobsy ins
um so yeah that would that would be
that um looks like we've actually gotten
to the end of the question stream which
is pretty good and i haven't
skipped anybody as far as i know um
so let's uh open it up to any other
oh that we've got some new questions
mark says what do i think of
christian thinkers like augustine's
defense of slavery should he have known
better
i think we always have to contextualize
these things you know um
and and in a lot of these cases we could
say
he could have used ideas against what he
actually did that were available
um but we also
we also want to be careful about well
what what counts as slavery would would
augustine for example have gone for
antebellum um american slavery or you
know think of you know mark you know
think about what would augustine what
would he have said about
apartheid you know and uh all the things
going on in south africa i think that in
a lot of these cases
the figures who are justifying slavery
it would not be
that kind of slavery right
uh william says the video my videos have
made him interested in religion can i
give suggestions on how to understand
christianity
because of covet i cannot directly go to
church read christian authors
you know engage with them as if they're
interlocutors
um you know see what they have to say
and
don't don't expect like the world out of
any particular one of them
but read you know read the people who
struggle the good bit with with
christianity
they're the ones that i find the most
interesting i always say
the thing the religious thinkers that i
find the most interesting are the people
who finding religion engaging with god
did not
simplify or answer all the questions in
their life it just made it more
complicated like
certain kierkegaard or like graham
greene
or iris murdoch or any any of these
these sorts of people you know um
bf vancleef what do i think about why
nations fail
the boom from a political perspective i
think there's many reasons why nations
fail i don't think there's
there's a uh a y to it i think there's a
whole bunch of intersecting wise
uh let's hook are you familiar with with
yong's work and your opinion on
mythology yeah i'm not a big fan of yang
people ask me about this a lot uh
jungians
always want me to be interested in young
i've read young i don't find
his stuff all that you know interesting
or convincing
i usually find him more interesting when
he's writing about other psychoanalysts
than when he's doing his own thing
um travdessel do you think our society
having such little regard of philosophy
has
helped this possibility of a new slave
class a lot of people aren't introduced
to philosophy
until college um studying philosophy
won't make you not
you know less slavish there's there's
you know there's so many other things
you could be
studying and you could study the wrong
kind of philosophy i mean if all you're
doing is talking about
possible world semantics i don't know
that that's necessarily going to make
you less
you know naturally slavish and aristotle
sense
i'm not sure what you mean by a new
slave class though um
so um
and i don't know what that has to do
with with aristotle as such
all right any other questions or
comments or
last things to go out on
looks like we have quite a few people
here so that's kind of nice
um i will mention too so you you've
seen mark in here mark mark and i are
friends
and collaborators and one of the the
ideas that he and i have been kicking
around for a while when we find the time
to do it because we're both busy
people is to work on
a a book taking aristotelian
problematics like the problematic of
slavery
and thinking them through in a modern
context
bringing to bear a lot of resources from
later philosophy and saying what can we
do with these
what what should we make of this in the
present how can we rethink these
really fruitful and fertile ideas
all right uh nicholas says can you
recommend a book that would help someone
who's been strongly religious for a long
time but is no longer a believer and
struggles with finding a purpose or
motivation in life
that's a good question i mean so you
don't want something religious you
probably want something
else i would say go back to ancient
philosophy
and you know read epictetus discourses
or or aristotle's nick and mccain ethics
or
plato's republic and see if those speak
to you at all
you know um
gabriel mulatto says what what 19th 20th
century christian writers would you
recommend i just gave some of them
graham green
you know i'm a fan of chesterton
although he is a little bit too clever
sometimes
um you know
certain kierkegaard um
gabriel marcel well worth reading uh the
guy wrote my my dissertation on maurice
blondell
um but there's i mean there's so many
people you could you could look at
um
so i can't read cyrillic so i'm not sure
how to pronounce this person's name
uh what's my opinion on musonius rufus
sonia's rufus is uh
an important stoic and you know teacher
of epictetus
it's unfortunate that we only have you
know 20 so of his lectures and some
fragments so we can't make
too much out of what he has to say but
you know
he's one of the stoics among many so
he's worth worth checking out
um a lot of people say sort of wrapping
up here and saying thanks
made of clay thoughts on agamben kingdom
and glory haven't read it
um uh jerome's sin high profits anyone
told you you look like penn gillette yes
for years but they usually also say the
dude and
you know stuff like that the the
gillette thing
you know it's that's harder to see i'm
not sure
why that's of interest to people but
all right mark uh oh that's cool so
that that's good um that has helped you
clarify some things related to your
doctoral work um and we're gonna chat
about that
he and he and i anyway down down the
line
but um yeah there's a good session um
glad we didn't have any like uh crazy
trolls coming in like we've had in the
past
um and uh hopefully this is
you know giving people uh both an
impetus to go
read politics book one read the whole
politics right
and also like a better understanding of
um you know what aristotle's
actual position on on slavery is
and why it's not so simplistic as oh
yeah he was cool with everybody being
slaves and
you know he thought that there was this
natural hierarchy and you can say
that that's actually bs you know you can
say that to the
people on the left who are like cancel
aristotle right
and or actually they don't usually say
cancel aristotle they
they get rid of him and then they get
accused of it by people on the right who
are like
aristotle's so great because he because
we love people being stuck in
hierarchies
you can say both of those sides are full
of crap you know
the real the real stuff is uh
more complicated as it always is uh but
much more interesting than that so
i am gonna say goodbye i gotta get to
doing some work on simplicius
for a paper that i'm i'm working on with
another one of my collaborators for the
aristotle and aristotelian uh tradition
conference coming up here in marquette
university in late june so
thanks to everybody for their questions
and i will see you next time